FOR A WHILE.
THE QUESTION IS WHO IS GOING TO
COME IN, WHO IS GOING TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO KEEP HIM IN LINE?
IS THIS GOING TO TURN THEM
AROUND?
I DON'T THINK IT IS.
>> THE REPORTS ARE IF YOU ARE
JUST JOINING US THAT THE
SUSPENDED BOSTON CELTICS HEAD
COACH ACCORDING TO REPORTS SAID
WITHIN 48 HOURS HE WOULD BE THE
NEW HEAD COACH BUT SEAN MARKS
THROWING COLD WATER ON THAT.
>> FIRST OF ALL STEVE NASH IS A
SCAPEGOAT FOR THESE PLAYERS
ACTING LIKE IDIOTS AND FOOLS.
IT IS REALLY STARTING TO BE A
JOKE, PAST BEING A JOKE.
I DON'T BELIEVE SEAN MARKS.
I THINK WHAT HAPPENED IS HE SAW
THE NEGATIVE REACTION.
I WATCHED TELEVISION ALL
AFTERNOON TRYING TO GET THE
INFORMATION BEFORE WE CAME ON
THE SHOW.
PEOPLE WERE GOING CRAZY THAT THE
GUY GOT A JOB THAT QUICKLY.
>> MR. UDOKA YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> YES.
I THINK THEY SAID WE'RE ALREADY
DOING A LOT OF STUPID STUFF.
WHY ARE WE GOING TO DO SOMETHING
STUPID TOMORROW?
THAT IS WHAT I THINK HAPPENED.
PRETTY DAMNED GOOD.
HE DON'T NORMALLY JUST GO OUT
THERE WITH STUFF, BUT I THINK
EVERY PERSON ON TELEVISION I SAW
THAT'S A LITTLE SOON TO BE
GIVING HIM A JOB.
>> IME UDOKA.
>> THIS IS WHAT I HEARD.
JUST WHAT I HEARD.
HE SAID FOE ONE IS HIRED.
HE NEVER SAID THAT IS NOT OUR
GUY OR HE IS NOT IN
CONSIDERATION.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
NOT BEING HIRED AND NOT BEING IN
CONSIDERATION.
FOR ME, LET'S SEE WHAT THE 48
HOURS BRING.
>> THE NEGATIVE EFFECT --
>> FIRST OF ALL I HOPE COACH
UDOKA GETS ANOTHER JOB.
HE DESERVES IT.
HE DID A FANTASTIC JOB.
I DON'T GET INTO PEOPLE'S
PERSONAL LIVES.
THAT BEING SAID, THIS IS NOT
WHAT THE -- WITH THE STUFF GOING
ON THERE, IT'S A BAD LOOK TO
BRING HIM IN.
>> YOU THINK SO?
>> YES
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> BECAUSE HE HASN'T SERVED ANY
PENANCE, KENNY.
>> THE PENANCE IS WITH THE
BOSTON CELTICS NOT THE BROOKLYN
NETS.
>> BUT TO DO -- WHATEVER
HAPPENED, HAPPENED.
BUT HE IS SERVING HIS PENANCE
WITH THE TEAM.
>> ACTUALLY WITH THE BOSTON
CELTICS.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
BROOKLYN.
>> IT'S NOT HIS FAULT --
>> PROBABLY GOING TO FIRE HIM
ANYWAY.
>> THEY PROBABLY ARE.
BUT IT'S JUST A BAD LOOK.
FROM A PUBLIC PERCEPTION YOU LET
THESE PLAYERS RUN THIS MAN OFF
HIS JOB BECAUSE THEY WERE ACTING
LIKE FOOLS, THE PLAYERS, THIS IS
ALL ON KEVIN DURANT AND KYRIE
IRVING AND BEN SIMMONS.
STEVE NASH IS A SCAPEGOAT.
IT IS REALLY UNFORTUNATE.
I DON'T KNOW IF STEVE NASH IS
RED AUERBACH OR WHATEVER.
THIS THING WAS NEVER GOING TO
WORK WHEN HE SAID WE DON'T NEED
A COACH.
>> IT'S NOT LIKE WE HAVE A
COACH.
LIKE WE'RE ALL THE COACH.
>> KYRIE, YEAH.
>> YOU KNOW, I WAS WATCHING
THESE SHOWS TODAY.
THIS TEAM DID PRETTY GOOD IN THE
PLAYOFFS LIKE THREE, FOUR YEARS
AGO.
SO NOBODY WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW
BAD A COACH STEVE NASH WAS THREE
OR FOUR YEARS AGO.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THESE GUYS START
ACTING LIKE FOOLS AND JA